now the point behind this move i'm
opening up the bishop
uh i invented this move actually e4 it's
never been played before
the you know the prophet arrived on the
scene
and rumor has it that the opponent of
the creator before alexander
kameko was so shocked by the genius of
this move that he simply lost on time
uh his internet service provider uh
was just uh so shocked by this as well
that they disconnected their service
they were derelict in their duty okay
let's go
[Music]
okay we are playing our first 2000 guys
we have not played a 2000 and i'm going
to play the c3 sittilian which
i've recommended to people in this
raiding range for a while thank you eric
for the thousand
so he goes d6 which is not the best line
against because it allows us to control
the center
now he attacks the pawn on e4 which
means that we need to defend it by
deploying our bishop
and there's a couple of subtleties to be
aware of here particularly if he goes
knight c6 yeah
so we we develop our knight to defend d4
now bishop g4 here looks very
intimidating i'll explain it after the
game he goes e6 which is very very
passive a very passive development by
our opponent
there's nothing special that we need to
do
to play against that but um
one well there's there's basically two
ways of playing here we can open up the
center
with dc which would make a lot of sense
or we can play
sort of flexibly we can play bishop g5
now let's do it by the book let's just
develop all of our pieces
knight b to d2 that is the downside of
the allopin you can't get the knight to
c3 but that's okay i mean the knight is
fine here
and it also buttresses the pawn on e4 so
we're definitely better
we've got a nice pawn center he's
probably going to go d5
and try to lock up the center but he's
going to be left with a lot of
positional weaknesses
and and he's going to be very cramped so
a successful it goes e5
now a lot of people struggle with this
scenario right how do we make a decision
between d
e d5 and and you need to use kind of
your intuition here right
d e would open up the position to his
favor it would
allow him to go d e and attack our
bishop so we go
d5 we keep the center closed and our
space advantage here
should in theory um you know
it it should cost him now there's
actually a tactical detail here that i
failed to anticipate
let's see if he finds it let's see if
yeah he does
knight d5 so i actually missed this move
uh but that's okay and this is the good
thing about being positionally better
you can blunder upon and you can still
be fine because
he's opened up the d file how can we put
pressure on the pawn on d6
what can we do to put pressure on this
pawn we can go knight to c4
no disaster has happened we've still got
a good position
uh but this is a very instructive
mistake that i just made they're
blundering that move
uh and i've even we've even had this
before on the other side
okay so we win back the pawn with with
our knight
and the position is about equal and i'll
show you guys after the game how i could
have done better than this
uh if he pushes with d5 we would have
taken and then the e5 pawn would have
been hanging
okay so let's see what he does we're
also attacking by the way the e5 pawn
he's got a nice knight on b4 though to
counterbalance that
the best move here would definitely be
queen to b6 preparing to
sizzle down that knight with rookie to
die in that case we need to evacuate
this knight it goes queen to c7
not i believe not the most accurate move
what does this allow us to do
why is this queen on c7 not ideally
placed well there's several things we
could do we could go knight to b5 with
tempo
and actually most people here would go
for rook c1
but here's the thing guys the knight on
d6 is the vulnerable piece here
so instead of using this get out of jail
free card
to activate our rook which we could do
later let's go knight to b5 let's
evacuate our knight because that's
priority number one
chess is all about priorities what is
the top priority
it's actually to get the night out guess
what we can do now
something we couldn't have done earlier
if this night was in trouble now it's
not in trouble it's defended
and i think he's forgotten what has he
forgotten about he's forgotten that the
pawn is hanging
and now we're over up upon uh so
yeah so sometimes chess is about
resisting the temptation right to do
something by the book
and to prioritize if he takes on a2
he's going to lose material and i'll
show that after the game
okay he goes a6 so he chases 2-2 think
he chases them sure
no problem we'll get the knight back to
c3 and even safer square
he's probably gonna yeah rook d8 now we
got to be careful right if we go queen
to e1 we walk into a fork
so where can we put our queen such that
it remains
hey ruin thank you where should we put
our queen
such that it remains active we should go
to a4 we apply pressure on the knights
okay queen c1 would have also been
possible this is just a little bit more
active okay
so let's see what he ends up doing
um he goes queen to c5 all right
he's attacking this knight he's not
actually attacking it though
uh because the b4 knight would hang uh
we need to make a move here that would
help the smoke clear a little bit
and we we need to use the opportunity of
the fact that the knight on e5 is not
really
hanging that knight on b4 is what's
causing a lot of problems for us
snyder before is like you guys can see
that it's cramping me down a little bit
so can we just
forcibly get it out of there how can we
forcibly get this b4 knight out
yeah let's go e3 i'm not really
attacking the knight
so much as i'm compelling him to go for
this trade
remember that we're up a pawn so trades
in general are good for us what's also
good for us is that he no longer has his
strongest piece
now he's sort of forked he's got to
probably drop his queen back
and uh he's losing the compensation that
he had for the pawn
although we still have a couple problems
to solve and he drops the knight
actually he blunders the knight
uh because you know he kind of just
panicked there
so very complicated 20 moves here that
you know
sometimes things end like this now here
we have a we have a nice little trick
i'm going to make the first move and if
he takes on b2
i want you guys to tell me the second
move we can win immediately
with a very very typical tactical idea
noticing that the queen is making
contact with the rook which means that
we can get our own rook to d8
and he simply cannot defend this rook he
has to go for the backrank checkmate or
he has to give up the rook
neither of which is appetizing and so
we've beaten her first two thousand
yeah he was good uh this guy put up a
big resistance particularly since i made
a tactical error
but uh okay so he's gonna continue
playing
um let's take with the rook
and we can continue you know harvesting
the garden here where the rook takes f7
because he cannot take
the queen is pinned if he takes the
knight we take his bishop
and that's another trade and that's
beneficial for us
now he's seen that he takes on e2 but
i've calculated one step further
can you guys find the mate in two moves
bingo as rosev sees it who else sees it
queen to f5 he can't cover because the
penny's got to drop his king back
and we're gonna fade his checkmate okay
so a good game
a sloppy one but nonetheless
okay so
let's see what he what he ends up doing
okay he's disconnected i think he's not
very happy
he thought he had me but you know you
can't give up gotta keep
keep pounding keep grinding
okay so
just quickly sorry about this game this
game so he played d6 right which gives
us control of the center this is a line
i've even played with black
now if he goes bishop g4 we go d5
and 95 here may look very good but white
has a very very nice
idea in this position and a typical one
right when this diagonal is open what
becomes possible
knight takes e5 bingo we're not
blundering the queen we're setting this
up
and when the smoke clears we're up a
piece this happens in so many different
openings it happens in the queen's
gambit
some of you guys might be familiar with
the famous queen's gambit version where
you play knight bd7
you seem to blunder the pawn but the
reality is you have bishop before
winning his queen back
then you capture the bishop and you're
up a piece same exact concept
so that's why we allowed ourselves that
now my mistake i think one of my key
mistakes
was actually the funny thing is
i don't think i should have developed
the bishop to g5 because it ended up
being a big liability
i actually think i should have probably
just taken got queen e2
and then put a rook on d1 to x-ray his
queen potentially even gone e5
to cement my central control we've seen
time and time again this bishop on g5
when it faces off with the bishop on e7
it gets into trouble precisely for the
reason that my opponent
displayed which is knight takes d5 and
this very same knight defends the bishop
if we take the knight
he takes the bishop and that bishop is
protected i've even
done this once in a classical game
against an im who blundered this
um couldn't we have just yeah we could
have taken on f6 we should have
uh but this basically relinquishes
whatever
you know whatever idea of an advantage i
had because it gives black the two
bishops he can then
redeploy his bishop and prepare f5 so
black has a good position here
um i showed that game not so long ago
yes because i had this
in a speedrun game but i decided to test
them it's very important to sort of
reorient right when you've blundered
something you blunt it upon you've
learned a piece even
you rethink your priorities you're no
longer better now your goal is to fight
back step by step
and reassess the situation so even
though we've blundered upon we have to
see the silver lining
which is that the d file has been opened
and with that the d6 pawn which is a
weakness
is easier to attack um and
and if he goes d5 then we take d5 he
takes back and we take e5 restoring
material equality
now if he had taken on a2 here what we
would have done is
knight to d7 forking the queen and the
rook
you guys might be looking no problem he
just takes what what the what's the big
deal but remember he's got a knight on
e2
now that knight is hanging as is the
other night it's a funny situation he
can't save both knights at the same time
uh so whenever you have a situation like
this where a piece defends another piece
that's why i call this a type 2
undefended piece
and i draw attention to it because it's
a very dangerous situation
which can basically ask for a piece
uh sorry there's a dingley wren playing
grisham ask for a piece to be overloaded
uh sorry here we go and so he goes a6
we drop our knight back we deploy our
queen and then the key moment here of
course he blunders the knight
he should have gone queen to c7 but now
we can bring a rook into x-ray his queen
and we've got uh we're basically in very
good shape here
what if you went bishop d7 in response
to a3
um well remember that the square is
covered right the square is covered by
the knight and the queen so that would
not have been
very advisable i did calculate the a2
thing i i mean
briefly uh so we go a3 just to clear up
the smoke get rid of his his strongest
piece
and and that's an underestimated way of
thinking what is my opponent's strongest
piece
how can i get rid of it right a3 gets
rid of it
and immediately things clarify we're in
good shape
uh yeah knight c6 i mean he's he's okay
but he's down a pawn and you know he
doesn't have much compensation for it
anymore because our pieces are now
nicely coordinated
my world ring is about 130 140 something
like that
let's go e4 and he plays the karakon
thanks 180. so
i don't think we faced the karaoke
before and to illustrate okay never mind
he doesn't play the
icon he plays d6 there's a funny story
about this move that i'll share after
the game
as we already know uh when our opponents
play stuff like this
we don't need to modify our strategy we
simply continue our development
and now there's two fundamental ways of
playing we can go f4
and occupy more of the center or we can
just continue our development with
knight f3 either
option is good um let's go f4 let's play
it like the romantics would have
now we have to be careful as i've
explained yesterday
the more center we occupy the more
pieces we need to bring in to supervise
that center we don't just want to keep
mindlessly expanding and expanding
because you know our empire is going to
collapse okay so he goes z5 striking in
the center
there's no need to respond to this
because both of our pawns are protected
uh so we can simply continue our
development where should we go
how should we continue our development
which piece should we develop where
should we develop it who can tell me
i'll explain later why why i get away
with this yeah absolutely bishop c4
uh good job and uh we're immediately
creating a line of fire to the pawn and
f now he's got to be very careful
my opponent is developing very passively
which means that okay he stops oh
we're gonna castle look at this f-file
okay this is gonna get very hairy for
him but we gotta play this well
so there's a couple of things that we
could do here again there's multiple
ways of playing a position like this
but there's no immediate win and uh he's
actually doing this
quite decently in the sense of avoiding
an immediate win
we can open the f file but he's put a
knight on f6 to block that file so i
wouldn't rush to play f65
what i would do is ask myself okay
um i we can go f takes e5 we actually
have a really really cool move
let me think about this for a second
this is actually a very interesting
moment
um hmm i'm actually doing some
calculation of my own
okay let's open up the file let's open
up the f file
and one thing that we can do after he
plays d takes e5 i assume he's going to
play dtake c5
we can take and go bishop f4 but we got
to be very careful about not giving him
a big time outpost right so what we're
actually going to do is d5
and after the game i'll explain this
move in greater depth but now look at
his queen and his knight they're just
biting on granite they're just staring
at this pawn now
we've basically left it in the dust if
that makes sense and the f-file is still
open so we still have that going for us
okay draconis thank you for the prime
now
we basically just need to find a way to
develop the rest of our pieces the
bishop is not developed
um and well first let's take on c6 let's
open up
the diagonal for the bishop before we
decide on anything else
now bishop e3 would have been a good
move
were it not for knight g4 but if you
notice what's wrong with knight g4 we're
going to play bishop e3 anyway hoping
for knight g4 because then we have a big
tactic i'll show that after the game
now he is threatening knight g4 we need
to stop that because that's going to
dislodge the bishop and then he could
put his queen on b6
how should we prevent knight g4 not a
difficult question not a trick question
how should we stop knight g4
don't be shy about making a move like h3
alright sometimes you gotta
you know even uh kings have to pee or
whatever i don't know
even you know you don't have to uh scale
everest with every move you make
something
just stop something like naichi for
that's totally fine now he sets up an
x-ray against the queen
let's get this queen out of there now
where why did i put the queen on e1 you
guys are
familiar with uh this maneuver where is
the queen going now we are going to
scale everest where is the queen going
is it going to h4 no it's not we're
going queen g3 because we are setting up
an x-ray against the king
what are we threatening we're
threatening bishop takes h6 we are
hoping for knight g6 that would blunder
a knight
remember that bishop on c4 didn't go
anywhere it's still there
and by playing h6 he's weak in the g6
square the pawn on f7
is paralyzed it cannot move so knight g6
would blunder the knight
he's in trouble because not only are we
threatening bishop takes h6 we're also
attacking the e5 pawn
and it's very important to get a full
sense of what you're threatening don't
zero in immediately on one thing look at
everything that you're threatening okay
so we can play bishop takes h6 but then
he has a very tricky response in knight
h5
which is actually quite annoying and i
will flesh this out in greater detail
after the game
one thing that we can well let's take on
e6
and um now if the bishop takes h6 again
he plays knight h5
and things get a little bit messy but h6
is not the only pawn that's hanging what
other pawn is hanging
can somebody tell me and what should we
take it with
e5 now we should take it with the queen
and after the game i'll explain and i'm
writing all this down i won't forget any
of this
why didn't we take it with the knight
there's a very specific tactical reason
for that
um and and so we take it with the queen
now bishop d6
almost traps our queen but it doesn't
because we have the f5 square
by the way the reason we didn't take
with a knight is because he would have
had bishop d6
now we have queen f5 and i believe that
we are
home free we also are threatening the
move e5
the f file didn't go anywhere that's
still up for grabs
yeah the knight would be pinned there's
some cool tactics here uh and and i'll
talk a little bit more about that after
the game
we're a little bit low on time so let's
expedite the process here
no need not to play e5 let's expand
let's get the bishop out of the picture
and then we can contest the defile if we
want to by playing rook a to d1
uh let's see where he goes everything
depends on where he goes with the bishop
okay so bishop c5 no need not to trade
we're up upon we're not against trades
and now we're going to bring the rook
into the game contesting the open d file
hopefully this makes sense
the knight on h7 is also very passive so
in this part of the game we're just
going to bring the rest of our pieces in
and then we're going to see depending on
what he does
we're just going to keep improving every
one of our pieces now i see this square
on d6
what piece could land on that square
with great effect
can somebody tell me what piece is just
it's
vying for that square absolutely get
that knight over there
damn girl and then well then f7 is going
to be under pressure
some of you might say wait a second
doesn't he win the pawn on b2
do i care i absolutely do not care let
him take it
okay so he takes this way he's probably
gonna go rook d8 no
all right well i guess i'll have to
prove myself so
let's move the king and if he takes it
we are going to descend upon him like
there's no tomorrow now knight d6 would
be tempting but let's not rush
before playing knight d6 we can slide
the rook into d7
uh so that knight d6 comes with more
tabasco sauce so to speak right
when you see a tempting move you don't
want to rush to play it you want to make
sure that you played in the best
possible version we're not winning here
it's not that simple uh but we are
attacking f7 and he
his position is on the cusp of
collapsing he's actually playing
extremely well
uh this guy is putting up a very good
resistance
but you can see that he's beginning to
show cracks
okay so we're going to take this knight
and now it's a simple task
of basically if we can move one of the
defenders away from the f7 pawn we'll be
able to take it
what should we do after he takes what
should we do
how yeah of course we should play h4 we
can't remove the rook but we can remove
the knight
knight has to move then we take f7 and
his position
collapses completely because we're just
going to have a devastating attack
against this king
and we should start thinking about what
we want to take on f7 he's probably
considering a move like g6
uh which which would prolong yep
so that's a good move but we're going to
slide the screen right over here to f6
and again he's finding only moves here
to survive knight h7 here would attack
my queen
and force me to attend to that threat
but it wouldn't solve the long-term
problem that he's facing which is that
f7 pawn it's still hanging
and guess what he might stave this off
for a couple moves thank you jacob c for
the but
you know he's making these one-move
threats but what he's not doing is is
solving the underlying problem here of
this pawn
but he is playing extremely well once
again i have to give him a lot of credit
here
okay so queen here let me think oh we
have a sick tactic
i think this works so we can play knight
takes f7 in the interest of time i'm
gonna
play this move now but can somebody tell
me the follow-up
what is the follow-up i'm removing the
defender here on what square
i'm removing the defender on which
square which square can i now
access with my queen the g6 square now
he's got two choices he can move to h8
but then he drops the rook or he can
move to f8 and then i'd like somebody to
tell me the checkmate
it's made in two take it away guys
i'm gonna sit back don't worry
everything's under control
and do the honors please
bingo good game
and definitely a lot to talk about let's
delve in so he played this and there's a
funny story about an
old russian master named vladimir
simagen
uh who was a grandmaster from the the
early 19th century
early 19th century i don't none of those
things were true i think he lived in
first half of the 20th century lord of
the bings thank you for the prime
and uh their story goes that he had a
long night on the town
and then he comes to the game the next
day and semagon plays c6 and then he
plays d6 and
and he was a karo khan player so his
friends after the game are like
a lot of me are like what are you doing
he's like well
i didn't have the strength to push the
pawn to d5 i don't know in russian this
sounds funny anyways he didn't have the
strength to play the karo khan
instead he played one of these openings
where you prepare the movie five
quite passive and why is f4
something i can get away with doesn't
this actually weaken my king
it does and i talked about this
yesterday
part of playing chess at this level and
above
is is all about making these
cost-benefit analyses
right i'm making this story up no it
actually exists in russian i think
uh but it is funnier in russian so it's
a cost-benefit analysis so on the one
hand we're occupying more of the center
on the other hand we're weakening our
king so the question i ask myself is can
i foresee a scenario
where he exploits my weakened king the
answer to that really is no
because look how passively he's already
developing i'm using that as a clue
to justify a slightly more ambitious way
of developing it's all about what your
opponent is doing
okay so we develop develop h6 is a good
move stopping knight g5 we castle
uh we open up the file and now the move
d5 basically leaving his queen
and knight in the dust if he would have
taken on deep oh ho
and the hype continues thank you chester
july david costa awesome channel
and great instructional content you
should check them out thank you for the
rate of the party of 114.
my lands we are having an epic first
hour of my stream
welcome guys i'm doing the speedrun
talking about my first game here welcome
everybody
thank you knit svj for the prime okay
so appreciate it david
now what would i have taken with here
what would i have taken with here and
this is to the point that chess is a
trade-off
chess is a complete game of trading one
advantage
for another
the bishop of course we don't want to
take with the knight we blunder the
bishop
every time a trade happens in the center
remember the rule every time a pawn is
captured in the center
you want to re-evaluate and see which
pieces are hanging
taco is hanging with ten gifted subs
holy smokes
it ain't stopping thank you jim jim so
we would have taken to the bishop now i
hear some of you guys saying wait a
second
isn't the bishop my strongest piece yes
it is but guess what
it's been replaced by an even stronger
piece the outpost on d5 you see what i'm
saying
okay so there should be some blah blah
blah
bishop e3 now had he played knight g4 to
chase my bishop
what cool tactic would white now have
who can spot it
thank you gem jam absolute absolute
legend
absolute legend
yeah bishop f7 is correct using the f
file driving the king and now a double
check which is a check from two
different sources
the reason double checks are good is
because the king is forced to move
by literally by definition and now we
recapture the knight we're up two pawns
and the king
uh has been totally decimated uh okay
so knight g4 would not have worked h3
now knight g4 would have been a threat
and by the way that's something that
people forget to do all the time
when a move fails for a tactical reason
you got to be very careful about not
assuming
that that reason is going to remain
throughout the game
that's one of the most common sources of
blunders i see at
all levels is a player makes a move
uh for example it might be a move where
you know let me give a very very simple
example
uh and if you guys just give me a second
proper gifting to just dodge i'm gonna
pull up my chest space so that i have it
for
instructional purposes not to make a
huge point out of this but i think this
is incredibly important for people's
development
so let's say that you decide
to do the following
just give me a second please i'm setting
up the chest-based scene this will take
me about
30 more seconds and then we'll delve
into the meat
okay we're almost there
just make this a little bit bigger okay
okay i think we're good this will be
fine
uh so let's take a a position like this
right
it's white to play thank you dbo 9000
for the sub
what should white do in this position
joe andrist 123 keeps the hype going
i know this is unbelievable we take the
pawn of course
now let's say that black plays the move
h6 here a very good example of
and i call this i don't actually have a
name for this but failure
to kind of pay attention to detail ah
you know i got okay i can play g4
that's fine he can't take the bishop oh
my god i
so that's obviously a very dumbed down
example nobody's actually going to do
that but you see what i mean
it's very easy to forget that the
situation has changed in a certain way
which makes it a tactical justification
no longer valid
carelessness i there's many names for it
but you see the point
all right so that's why we played h3
now we get the queen to g3 and now the
tactics begin
so by the way knight g6 we would have
taken the knight he can't take
because of bishop takes g8
so okay the point that i wanted to make
is that there is a certain level 17 1800
in which at some point things just boil
down to calculation
not not everything can be explained by
logic alone
sometimes you just have to sit down and
calculate
and the fact that the tactics work out
in one player's favor
isn't necessarily itself the product of
some sort of
higher being that's organizing things
chess has a lot of coincidence and
chance in it
and things that don't always make
logical sense so bishop takes h6
would look very good intending to
checkmate
but it would allow knight h5 right
attacking the queen and simultaneously
defending g7
the queen cannot remain on the g file
which means that not only do you give up
this bishop but the other bishop is
saying
but if you would have first taken on e6
as i did and now taken on h6
this is a very tough situation again
because we can't move the queen away
from the g file and if we move it up to
g4
what is black going to do can somebody
tell me what black is going to do here
and this puts me in a bind from which i
literally cannot get out
notice that both knights are defending
g7 so we can assign
a different task to one of the knights
this is going to be a three-time
repetition
because to avoid the draw i have to give
up a piece i can try to sacrifice it
but that's very iffy does that make
sense so that's why bishop takes h6 was
bad
queen takes c5 instead was my choice the
reason i didn't take with a knight
because of bishop d6
pinning the knight to the quake to the
uh to the queen i know some of you guys
are saying whoa whoa
i can take this knight now but he plays
bishop takes c5
forking the queen of the rook lots of
tactics here a little plucking another
raid 37 welcome people
thank you uh thank you mark for the raid
so does that make sense
and that's why we take queen takes c5 e5
takes rook d1 contesting the file
getting the knight to an outpost
getting the rook in first and now up to
the last tactic
so here i could have played c4 to
intercept the queen
from f7 right somebody well nick mullins
would have played this move in a second
uh i mean interception tactics
no problem but i played a better move
here knight takes f7 is the tactical
solution
and and this is a form of removing the
defender the reason that i do this is
because i want to give the check on g6
but obviously i
well i can but that wouldn't be very
advisable so by removing the defender we
slide the queen in
his king has to maintain contact with
the rook
if he moves the side i go rook takes f7
but king f8 leads to this checkmating
pattern which is actually
quite common right if you solve a lot of
problems that's why
problem puzzle solving is so important
it it awakens your mind to these kinds
of patterns without it
you won't find something like this it or
or it'll take you a lot longer
uh well i played king h2 because i was
in check so no big
big reason i i kind of chose king h2
king h1 at random uh i think both moves
would have been fine
i didn't play king h1 the reason is i
was a little bit worried about a
background check potentially so king h2
i thought
was marginally safer but you can never
predict you know sometimes one is safer
sometimes the other is safer
any questions ladies and gentlemen and
please i always say this and i always
mean it
do not be shy about asking questions
that's the entire premise the speed run
right is for everybody to sort of fully
understand everything as much as
possible
and if you ask a question that's
actually a very selfless thing to do
because most likely everybody else has
that question in their mind anyway
um what if he took with a king okay
so what if he had just responded to d5
asks drum
uh with c5 well that's a great question
but look at this pawn that would have
been created as a consequence we can go
knight b5
and then shove this pawn through to d6
and get the knight to c7
so this would have allowed me to create
this massive pass pawn which i would
have pushed pushed even further
um what's the meaning of life what is my
social security number great questions
there i have played d4 actually
will the niners make the plays well not
after yesterday
um yeah so i would advise people to play
rapid 15-minute chess when you're first
starting and then slowly if you like
blitz you can transition to it but
definitely wrap it to start
what if black had played knight h5
straight after queen g3
yeah so i would have taken the pawn here
and and that's why i mentioned it's
important to be aware of everything that
you're attacking with a particular move
uh and now f7 would have fault as well
would have fallen as well
[Music]